do you think a woman should be president
no the based grandmothers afraid of no
one and this 300 lb gorilla comes out
what do you mean by Gorilla what in this
video I'll be talking to four
80-year-old grandmas about the most
pressing issues of society the woman
will have a monthly and she'll drop the
Anam bomb and what their wisest advices
for us younger people do not get anyone
pregnant I drove over to my aunt paty's
house gave everyone the traditional
welcome kisses but before getting into
the first question they had to do a
little cleaning look at this oh my God
god well this is going to get a lot of
views do women nowadays do this yes when
comes only when company
[Laughter]
come wait I'll
draw why do you think 50% of couples get
divorced now cuz men cheat cuz men cheat
no I think women are more indep
dependent today and they don't need it
to take the [__] from their husband
so they say goodbye is this the next
rated mov she us retract
that you think they're smarter today
absolutely but then why do 50% of
couples get divorced if they're smarter
are you listening I just told you well I
hear that but like because women don't
take they don't have to put up with the
man today if he his controlling ways or
so do you think it's a good thing the
divorce rate goes up yeah I do because
women are women are coming up in life
women are ENT trapped into the marriage
like they were do you think a woman
should be president no no no no because
a woman will have a monthly and she'll
drop the Anam bomb I
mean I still think the president a man
is more powerful in that position than a
woman should women be policemen no yes
you want to be polic if you're a a woman
policeman and I think five six of 55 is
the height requirement and you're this
big and this 300 lb gorilla comes out
what do you mean by Gorilla what big man
big man not racist no no no not racist
don't use that word it could be no it
could be when I say that I need a big
all right a
300b men
monkey that what is she going to do hand
them a banana yeah wait no no no the
women have tasers the woman cops have
tasers you think a woman cop with a
taser is going to take down a guy oh not
me personally no he can she can if she
gets close enough she gets close enough
with that before she gets close enough
she'll be she's dead the gorilla will
get her the gorilla will get her leave
the men's job to to the men and yes a
woman's job to a woman I mean and I
don't mean uh doctors nurses lawyers or
anything like that that could be a man
or a woman because you're using your
mind but the strength jobs that you have
to have strength for yeah I mean I was
riding by I remember years ago a
construction site when women first
started using the Jackhammer and you
know where that woman was on the job she
was standing next to him the men would
be using Jack camera so she was getting
paid money the benefits and she was
watching how many genders are there two
how wait but I thought there was like a
100 I don't you mean who said woman
that's what I learned in school well
that school you should have quit when
did people start um making up genders
when did this happen when Biden became
President when Biden became
president would you rather Joe Biden or
Nikki H Haley is President neither
neither I rather run the country
myself
I don't get the monthly anymore and I
would not make grass decisions he's a
puppet he gets he has all the Democrats
behind him telling him what to say where
to go he can't speak for himself I mean
the man obviously has some form of
dementia and I'm being serious and he
should not be in the position but who do
we have next KLA Harris that that's
worse a woman monkey a woman monkey no
I'm joking with bananas
yeah when you guys were growing up what
made a woman a ho she slept with
everybody she slept with everybody and
didn't get money how many people a lot
one if she wasn't married she was a
[__] it was one back in the day yeah
one was a [__] more than one was a home
that was the
rules was it normal where couples got
married the woman was a virgin yes yes
that was like the regular well three of
us here were yeah three of us here were
guess which one I'm not going to guess
that I was a virgin a year after I got
married she's I like who the hell
invented this how did they know how to
do
[Music]
this women were virgins back then like I
said three three of us
were so it was one a [__] and two plus
a HOA yeah well a [__] and a h they're
very close though yeah they're the same
thing as far as I'm to what neighborhood
you came from they called same same [__]
that's a prostitute prostitute gets paid
prostitute gets I never got paid oh you
found out the one we found out here's
the one I told you we would go to the
movies with our husbands and and and if
the scene came on and went off to the
stars in the sky you know you knew use
your imagination now today they're doing
it right on the screen so I never knew
when I was young we never thought about
we never thought about it what it was
that's what they were doing but it was
you had no idea no had no idea that was
it today it's right on the
screen couple with a girl you're getting
horny in the
movies so you're saying when you were a
kid it was like maybe they held hands
and then they went like up to the up to
the stop and that was it you were like
oh that was it were the guys very
respectful back then like cuz now guys
are very pushy and like a lot of dudes
if they don't get action on the first
date they're like surprised but that
that wasn't even a thing growing up
always used to tell my husband I'm not
the change I'm not the change yeah
because he paid for the dinner and now
he gets the change you're not the
dessert well no I used to say I'm not
the change should I was dessert I should
have said dessert we never
deserve they were very respectful not
that they didn't we didn't argue with
our boyfriends and whatnot naive and and
it's okay to be like that I think to a
degree I would not want to be a young
person in today's world cuz you go on a
date like you said you want action on
the first night I mean and what you take
me to McDonald's if you were if you were
lucky if you were lucky yeah no I I
think we were better in our day what do
you think of modern girls my age so the
divorce rates at over 50% every girl has
over 10 Partners previously oh my God
it's fine you think it's fine and
today's day and age if the guy can go
out and screw everything around why
can't the girl but what's the only way
that a guy can go around and screw a
bunch of things you're single well isn't
it if women let them yeah women let it
and you some women go out there cuz they
want it why do you think women nowadays
want it but back in your day that wasn't
a thing well because we didn't know any
better yeah was we was sheltered and we
were scared the heck of our parents
don't you think that's almost a good
thing that you guys were sheltered and
you weren't shown so much garbage like
my generation I I do have you heard any
of the recent music that like they they
they show to kids talking about
promiscuity and all what's going on in
the school what's going on in the school
yeah it's terrible I I think it should
be here I have a song to play for you
guys let's get your reaction better be
respectful have you heard of sexy red
[Music]
[Applause]
no this is the new one of the new hit
songs holy
[__] where the [__] I'm looking for the
ho [__] CU suck a [__] to
yeah my coochie pink my booty hole Brown
what do you think of these re
revolutionary lyrics gross disgusting
gross and disgusting so do you think
that millions of people consuming
garbage like this leads to people doing
degenerate activities yes yes yeah what
advice would you give me as a
20-year-old coming up in the world well
I would say to you you are very
fortunate very successful real quick to
add on to that a lot of the business
stuff I've been doing doing lately is
related to short form marketing so Tik
Tok Instagram reals YouTube shorts and
these platforms are paying out crazy
money per thousand views like Tik Tok
right now it's a dollar per thousand
views and then the other thing with
these other ones is you use the views
you get to drive them to a product and
make thousands in the process this is
like what I've mastered over the last
few years so if you want to learn how
you can do the same even as a complete
beginner I'm hosting a live class to
teach you so check the link in the top
of the description to see if there's any
more spots and yeah back to the video
Don't Let It Go to your head and don't
think who the hell you are because you
have this great not personally you
because you have this great car and you
have this good money you got to think 10
15 years down the road where you're
going to be and be smart about yourself
do not get anyone pregnant always call
your mom your parents and be cuz you
don't realize what family is whatever
you do the consequences affect your
family your mother your father your
sister your brothers how is it Haven
killed off all your
husbands better them than us yeah better
better than
us you know what I have to tell you when
you first lose a spouse you're of course
you're upset and whatnot and you think
your life is never going to be the same
but there's a lot of perks to
it what are the perks to losing a spouse
well when you go on vacation you paying
for
one you know you you pay for one you
have the freedom of the television you
can click it you you think so wait you
can click any station you want you can
go to bed I didn't have my husband
coming down you're coming
up CU she had to do her last chore last
to do my last chore of the day you know
but oh and it was a chore not all the
time but lots of times
how how old is everyone I'm 83 83 77
81 I'm trying to pass for
80 80 okay what is your biggest regret
in life if you could go back and change
something not having sex before I was
married Bro my biggest regret is I wish
I was educated more I wish we had the
mentality or the parents that would send
us you're going to college does it feel
like being 80 years old your life has
gone by really quick or it feels like a
long life oh went by quick I think it's
a long life long life yeah long life
long life I don't know I I just went
yeah came in here we are because
mentally we're not in our 80s we don't
feel you know we say oh I'm going to do
this I'm do that and it doesn't happen
but it's okay because in my case and I
guess all of our cases we're healthy and
we live our lives to what I'm happy at
whatever I was I like I don't say I hate
it this I hat never really much of a
complainer no not with my age not with
age age never bothered me until I look
in the
mirror how do you think that we fix
Society what are the main things what
are the new values we need to instill
that maybe you guys had growing up but
aren't a thing anymore some morals
morals morals respect your last name our
politicians and he for these people and
get new people in there that could teach
us morals
again parents are responsible for your
morals I think the government is
responsible from where are they getting
they're hearing yeah but I know but you
instill I'm sure your mother instilled
certain values in you think so too
matter what's out there you know what
you were T of course if I listen to
school I would still be um I would still
be in college and I would think there's
24 genders yeah right yeah is there
anything else you guys would like to
talk about talk about you for a little
bit I was just going to say that ask me
you can ask me some questions maybe that
will give you a different perspective of
um okay but honestly
honestly have you ever been close to
someone I know I know you have a low
opinion of women that's what I get out
of
you is that what you get from my videos
that's what I no that's what I get from
talking to you videos you think so well
wouldn't you have a low opinion of the
the women nowadays but why is it okay
for you to go get the woman and screw
her for the night but that makes her a
bad person but don't make you a bad
person but today it's she's not a bad
person they're own
no today because well I don't I don't
really go around doing that to begin
with but well now and then I'm well the
simple answer is like you guys as a
woman this is how I look at it you have
unlimited access so like from the age
you turned 16 to 22 you could have had a
new partner every single night just
because of the fact that you're a woman
right like cuz men are pigs and so our
generation yeah not our generation you
don't think that you could have found a
guy every well we probably could have
but that's not
we saying you could have you could have
like you had the access to so as a woman
since you have unlimited access access
what makes it valuable is Li who you
limit the access to then as a guy you
have to work I mean to be able to sleep
with a new girl every night you'd have
to be Brad Pit and he still probably
wouldn't even be able to do that so it's
it's different that's why like people
say it's not it's it's um well if if
women do it why why are you not mad at
the men for doing it and it's because we
have different access so if there's
different access there's different value
attached to it and also access yeah but
yeah I'm was going to say well but
you've got all these clubs that go to
and all these women yeah but it's the
men going there to get the girls yeah
but they're there you know where to go
yeah but you don't just like you there's
still guys that go to a club spend tens
of thousands of dollars and they still
can't even get a girl as a girl you
could be fat and ugly and still go home
with a guy every single time you met
sneo recently and he was adorable you
like I did I liked him a lot but when I
I watched his videos I like his name I
got a different impression on his videos
and his personal
life I mean we were with him 5 minutes
we didn't me along but he was different
than what he presents on his videos you
know he's really a good person I think
from what I got to know I watched uh I
like the gambling channels and I watched
this uh stepen who done
it Steve will do it yeah Steve will do
it St he lives in my building oh
does I love him you like Steve I but you
know why I turn it off because of the
language that's why bad that's why we
take off be that's why we take off I'll
tell them I'll tell them I turn it off I
I like him he just lost a million
dollars you watch Steve will do it told
that's the most random thing he hands
money out to people he's bought he's
bought cars he just passes by and giv
you
$110,000 where where is this guy so the
other day I'm watching him and he
Blackjack he likes Blackjack and I like
um Vegas Matt I watch him too and I was
watching Steve who did it done
it been to that and he lost a million
dollars and his friend lost money and he
set down at the table he says this isn't
for me today my friend lost whatever he
lost 600 there whatever I win my friend
is getting this course he lost money a
that's the kind of guy he is and they
had a documentary on him and he's really
a likable nice guy the only thing I
don't like about a show he takes too
long to start
gambling maybe I'll try to get you guys
to meet that would be fun would you like
to meet you like to meet Steve will do
it all right what other concerns about
my videos or criticisms I like these I
think your subjects you said uh what do
you think of black black um what what
was that black people can black people
be racist oh can black people be racist
and then you come up with I have a black
brother my step brother is black I said
when did that
happen you didn't know about that no
black people can be racist I worked with
a girl years ago and she was a very
light skinned black person with freckles
and all her siblings were really dark
and she used to come into work crying
because they used to tease the heck out
of her she said they used to call her
all these names because she was not
truly black I think everyone has racism
in them I don't care what they say to a
point there's some there someone in your
life black people don't want you to they
don't want their people to marry white
either you know a lot of them don't they
want keeping your own race keep no but
they feel that way true it's true I know
they do and then we feel that way it's
beautiful yes yes all right all and give
your mother some credit a lot of credit
thank you and what it be on Youtube
it'll be on the YouTubes the Tic Tac
never
be how you want I know that it's a bit a
pill it's hard to fight a battle when
you're going up hill